foreign
hunted for knowledge in the unknown
the Wonder is
not that the field of stars is so vast
but that we have measured it
[Music]
thank you
we're all here because we're committed
to the biggest question of all what's
[Applause]
[Music]
your part of constellation now
part of our family
[Music]
we do not fully understand all that is
at work here no finer group in the stars
to be unraveling this mystery
grab jump is ready I love this part
these artifacts could be everything
we've been looking for another great
secret the universe is asking us to
unravel
[Applause]
the settlements throughout the Galaxy
could be at risk
all right
we are not stopping whatever lies at the
end of this road
will change Humanity forever
this
is Where We Belong
[Music]
[Applause]
play a day one with Xbox game pass